All right. So this is an intimate session, and we're all very
relaxed and very happy to see our friends in the audience.
And we're very grateful that you are
really nice troopers. We are very excited, and we hope
that you would as well. So
we
naturally decided to use the pancreatic cancer as a
model to talk about silent less lesions
and
potentially some means for harnessing the natural
tumor-suppressive aspect of the microenvironment as
potential interception and prevention for pancreatic cancer.
And we're going to be giving several examples using pancreatic cancer even though
it wasn't in the model, because that's naturally how
we levitate, I guess.
So,
with no further ado, I want to introduce my dear friend and colleague,
Laura Wood, who is going to... I'm going to read your
title, so I'm going to be a little more proper that way.
Molecular and cellular alterations associated with malignant
progression in the pancreas.
Good morning, everyone. Oh, this is kind of slanted.
I'm worried that's going to fall, so I'm going to put it here.
Thank you to the organizers and to Eti for inviting me to share some work today,
and thank you to the audience for staying through till the end.
As Eti mentioned, we're going to be using pancreatic cancer as an example to talk
about molecular and cellular alterations in precancers.
I have no disclosures.
So since I'm the first speaker, I wanted to just start by giving some of the
background of why pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma, or PDAC, is an important
disease to study. Probably everybody in the room knows that it has a dismal
survival rate,
partly due to late detection, but it highlights that
there's important opportunities for prevention and interception.
And I think one of the big focuses in my lab is leveraging human tissue samples to
meet these goals.
And the way that we think about it is if we want to do data-driven interception, we
need to understand precancers, how they occur in humans.
So again, as the first talk, I thought I would level set a bit and introduce the
two different types of precancers in the pancreas.
So the majority, about 90% of pancreatic cancers, arise through
microscopic precancerous lesions.
These are called pancreatic intraepithelial neoplasia or PanIN.
These are by definition less than five millimeters, which means they can't be seen
on traditional imaging studies. They also can't be seen in grossly
resected pancreas specimens if you're looking with the naked eye.
Makes them challenging to study.
PanINs are graded based on the morphologic features of their epithelium into
low-grade with minimal atypia, and then high-grade, thought to be the step
immediately prior to invasive carcinoma.
An important minority of pancreatic cancers, again, somewhere between 10 and 15%,
arise through larger cystic precancers.
The most common one of these is intraductal papillary mucinous neoplasm or
IPMN. These are by definition greater than a centimeter, but they can get much
larger. This means they can be identified on imaging.
They can also be identified in a grossly resected pancreas specimen if you want to
harvest tissue for research. It makes them easier to study, but also creates
clinical conundrums in that they're often identified incidentally, and we have
to decide who needs a resection to prevent pancreatic cancer versus who can be
safely watched.
IPMNs, like PanINs, are graded based on the morphology into low-grade and
high-grade.
So when I first started my group several years ago,
we focused a lot on IPMNs because of their larger size and convenience to study,
but obviously if 90% of pancreatic cancers arise through PanINs, we
ignore them at our peril. So we'll start by talking about IPMNs, and then we'll
switch over to PanINs.
So anyone in this audience who knows me knows that I do a lot of neoplastic cell
focused work, looking at genomics and other neoplastic cell alterations.
So I will talk a little bit about that.
When I first got the invitation from Eti to speak, I was a little surprised because
we don't do a ton of stuff with stroma, but we do have some exciting unpublished
recent data on IPMNs and stroma, so I'm excited to see what the group thinks about
it.
But I want to give a high-level overview of studies from
over several years now, looking at multi-region genomic analysis and how
it provides insights into precancer evolution.
So the first is that IPMNs
often have a polyclonal origin, so the initiating oncogenic
mutation in IPMNs is usually either KRAS or VRG2.
Low-grade IPMNs often have multiple mutations in one of these initiating
mutations, and we've shown using more comprehensive sequencing that these really
are independent clones within the same lesion.
When an IPMN progresses, there's additional genetic alterations, and you have one
of those clones that takes over. So the high-grade IPMNs are homogenous
with respect to KRAS and VRG2, but then they have convergent evolution with respect
to other driver gene mutations.
We have lots of evidence over several years about multifocal neoplasia in
IPMN patients. The first is that if somebody gets an
IPMN that's surgically resected, they do have a risk of
recurrence or progression in their remnant pancreas.
And when this happens, if you genetically analyze both, the thing that comes back
in the remnant is usually just a completely separate lesion, independent IPMN,
sharing no genetic alterations with the thing that was originally resected.
Really highlighting that it's a disease of the entire pancreas with multiple
independent neoplasms spread throughout.
When you have an IPMN with a carcinoma that's occurring at the
same time, resected together, there is a small but substantial percentage of these
that are, again, independent lesions, where the IPMN and the cancer
in the same pancreas resected at the same time actually share no genetic
alterations.
When IPMNs, though,
when they occur with cancers, most of the time they are related, and we've done
really detailed genomic analysis and shown,
I think quite definitively, that IPMNs can be precursors to invasive
cancer.But one of the key questions, it's a
major transition to go from an IPMN that is essentially curative surgically
resected to an invasive cancer. What drives that transition?
It's clinically very important.
And we've shown that sometimes it can be driven by a somatic mutation.
We did a study where we did whole exome sequencing of IPMN and adjacent
cancer and showed that in, I think it was
four cases, there were cancer-specific mutations that were in the
cancer, not in the adjacent IPMN, and SMAD4 or TGF-beta
receptor II. This makes a lot of sense with what we know about that pathway.
There's an example shown here where the IPMN and the cancer shared a mutation in
KRAS. They shared a mutation in p53.
They shared a mutation in p16. But the SMAD4 nonsense mutation was only
in the cancer.
So again, about a quarter of the cases had a cancer-specific mutation in something
in either SMAD4 or TGF-beta receptor II.
But I think the flip side of that is equally, if not more interesting, which is
that most of the time there's not an obvious genetic alteration that drives
malignant progression. And I think this raises the question of if it's not a
genetic alteration, what could it be?
So we wanted to look in detail at the tumor microenvironment
and how it's altered with malignant progression.
So we took 12 patients who had IPMNs and small invasive
carcinomas. We did comprehensive genomic analyses of these cases
as well, but the data I want to show is from imaging mass cytometry that we did in
collaboration with Wan Jin Ho using a 38-plex TME focus panel.
We quantitatively defined regions of interest in the cancer, the
IPMN, and then what we called the transition zone, where it was a mixture of the
two.
We compared the densities and other quantitative metrics of all the different cells
in the microenvironment. But what turned out to be the most interesting or the most
different between the IPMN and the cancer were the fibroblast populations.
We saw that there were some fibroblast populations, like these indicated in yellow
and green, that were expanded in the invasive cancer,
and then other fibroblast populations, like the green and orange here, that
were decreased in the invasive cancer and expanded in the IPMN.
Again, we quantified this. This is looking at density and showed that some
fibroblast populations are
low in the IPMN, expanded in the cancer.
Other fibroblast populations are high in the IPMN and
then diminished in the invasive cancer.
When we looked in more detail at this imaging mass cytometry data, we saw that
these fibroblast populations occupied distinct spatial niches.
So the H&Es I'm showing here are from those transition zones where you have
IPMN and invasive carcinoma in the same small region, showing that
there's some fibroblast populations that are really right around the IPMN
and not in the cancer, and then other populations that are more in the cancer
and not in the IPMN.
When we were looking through this data, we saw that the immune populations in these
niches were also distinct. So Jesse, who is the PhD
student leading this, worked with Wan Jin Ho to develop a way to quantify
the immune cells that were in these fibroblast niches.
They developed this approach called Clover Patch, which is in press now,
very excitingly.
But what it allows you to do is to,
in an automated way, annotate fibroblast
neighborhoods and then quantify the other cell types within them.
And what we saw is in the cancer-specific fibroblast TMEs, there were
fewer T cells, but also differences in the types of T cells that were there.
And with the IPMN-specific TMEs, we saw a lot more
granzyme positive cytotoxic T cells as well as memory T cells.
And we're still really working through all of the quantification of this data,
so stay tuned for when that's done.
The ultimate goal of this, though, is to do really an integrated analysis, not just
the TME or just the genomics, but to have the set of samples that are really
deeply characterized with respect to their genomic alterations as well as the
TME.
So as I mentioned, 90% of pancreatic cancers arise through these microscopic
pannens.
So I want to spend a little bit of time talking about these.
I will say that our stroma-focused work is more limited in the pannen
space, but thankfully we have two other experts on this, so I hope I can set the
stage for them to present their stromal data.
So because of pannen's small size,
we needed to come up with new approaches to really do tissue quantification to
understand how many pannens were present in the normal pancreas,
how big a pannen is, and how they might be connected.
So we worked with Ashley Keman and Dene Wertz to develop this approach called CODA
that allows us to do 3D quantification of pancreatic tissue.
This is showing a three cubic centimeter piece of normal pancreatic tissue.
This is showing different cell types, normal duct in blue and pre-cancer in red.
It's going to zoom in to show you
adding in the periductal collagen, the blood vessels, the islets of
Langerhans, the fat, and the acinar cells.
It's going to zoom in to show you that you get single-cell resolution in these 3D
models, and then it will zoom out to show you that within this about three cubic
centimeters of tissue, we get the precise 3D location of almost a billion
cells. And again, this 3D modeling approach was
developed by Ashley Keman, Dene Wertz, and Peijun Wu.
We applied it to a large cohort of grossly
normal pancreas from pancreatic surgery resections.
And what we were really struck by with these first few models we did was
that there was a lot of pre-cancer.
So we wanted to investigate
whether these pre-cancers were one large pre-cancer or spread throughout the
pancreas.
This next video is going through the 3D image stack that we used to build the 3D
model, and in this, each spatially separate pannen is annotated in a different
color.
And what I hope you can see in this is that there's lots of different colors here.
There's many different pannens. It's then going to show you the 3D model, and what
you'll see is the tissue falls away with normal duct in blue, and every other
color is a spatially separate pannen. But simply, there's a lot of pannens in here.
There's more than 10 spatially separate pannens in this three cubic
centimeter piece of pancreas.It also really
shows you the level of anatomical and molecular detail you get in these 3D
models. We can really understand
where these PANMs are, how they involve the ductal system, and I think there's a
huge opportunity with these models to understand the environment around
the PANMs as well.
So this CODA approach, which is the 3D modeling approach developed by Denis Ashley
and Pei Xu, lets us do characterization of PANAM size, connectivity, and
number. We then scaled it up. We modeled
exactly 45
blocks of grossly normal pancreatic tissue.
This is showing some examples of the blocks that we analyzed.
I do want to emphasize these were adjacent normal from surgical
resections. A third of the cohort had pancreatic cancer.
The other two-thirds were having a resection for another reason.
But it's not truly normal, which is what we'll hear about, I think, from the next
speaker. In all of these, normal duct is blue, and every other color is a
spatially separate PANAM. So what I hope you can take from this is that,
number one, all of the blocks we modeled had multiple PANMs within a relatively
small sample of pancreas, but there is a fair bit of variability patient to
patient on the number and size of the PANMs.
We looked at how the amount of PANAM correlated with the amount of other tissue
within a block. This is maybe one of the more stromal relevant PANAM
observations in this data set
because we saw that the amount of PANAM within a tissue block was directly
correlated to the amount of collagen or ECM in the block.
We saw it was inversely correlated to the amount of acinar cells.
So what this suggests to us is having PANAM is associated with having fibrosis and
having atrophy of the acinar cells.
Excuse me.
But I think one of the challenges with these observational data sets in human
tissue is you don't know the direction of the causation here.
It could be that inflammation predisposes to PANAM and also
predisposes to atrophy and fibrosis, or it could be that the PANAM obstructs
the ductal system and directly causes the atrophy and fibrosis.
We wanted to come up with a kind of intuitive metric of PANAM burden, and
what we came up with was simply to count the PANMs per cubic centimeter of tissue.
We thought this
made sense with how we were thinking about them.
And what we found was that the mean PANAM burden in our cohort was 13
PANMs per cubic centimeter of tissue.
And if you can visualize how big a cubic centimeter is, it's not very big.
So to have 13 spatially separate precancers in such a small area, to us, was
quite striking.
We then calculated
the mean number of PANMs in the entire pancreas based on that PANAM burden and got
about 1,000.
This is a very noisy estimate for reasons we can discuss in the Q&A, but I think
it's still orders of magnitude more than we were expecting.
We then came up with an approach to do 3D genomic analysis of the PANMs.
We did laser capture microdissection and integrated that in with the 3D models.
I'm not going to show you this in great detail.
It is published, but I'll go over the broad strokes of the
results. We found that almost all of the PANMs we sequenced had
KRAS hotspot mutations. The hotspot mutations occurred in the same distribution
as you see in advanced PDAC, selecting that these KRAS mutations are selected at
PANAM initiation. Like in IPMNs, we found
that when there were multifocal PANMs, they were independent neoplasms that didn't
share any somatic mutations. And we found that, again like IPMNs,
large PANMs can have a polyclonal origin.
Much of our data was focused on point mutations.
We did also look at copy number, and we found that aneuploidy and
extensive copy number alterations was rare in PANMs, even in high grade.
Ashley Keman in collaboration with us, but Ashley was the one
that led this part of the study. She wanted to come up with a way to measure the
inflammation in the PANMs. This was focused on CD45
positive inflammatory cells. I think similar approaches can be used
to measure stroma. But what we were really struck with when we did this
3D quantification of the immune microenvironment was how
heterogeneous it was even within one PANAM.
So this is one spatially contiguous PANAM.
The images on the left and the right are both different regions of that same PANAM,
and you can see on the left there's very little inflammation.
On the right, there's a ton of inflammation.
So the immune and stromal response to these lesions is very
heterogeneous, even within one contiguous PANAM.
And I think this is important for a couple of reasons.
First, the heterogeneity of the PANAM inflammation.
It raises the question of what are the biological drivers of this heterogeneity?
Why is one region of the PANAM so inflamed while other regions are not?
It also impacts the study design as we think about how do we want
to study the microenvironment in these human tissues, because you would get a
very different answer if you were to apply a highly multiplex technology,
depending on which section you chose to apply it to.
So with this, I want to summarize.
I hope I've shown you that pancreatic precancers, both IPMNs and PANMs, are
multifocal.
The progression of these can be driven by somatic mutations, but often it seems not
to be. And I want to raise the question, especially in this session, of whether
microenvironmental features could be an alternative driver of progression in some
lesions.
We've shown using detailed analysis of imaging mass cytometry that
fibroblast populations are distinct between cancer and pre-cancer regions in
IPMNs.
We haven't shown the relevance of this to PANMs, but I think we'll hear
our next speakers talk more about the stroma around the PANMs.
And then finally, I think a note of caution is that the microenvironment is
heterogeneous even over short distances around these precancers.
So we need to think about this with study design and interpretation.
So the overall concept of this session was focused around interception.
So I wanted to close by thinking about what these results might mean for
interception. I think low-grade precancers, both IPMNs and PANMs, are
incredibly common, but they almost never progress.
Again, a very rough calculation just to be provocative.
It's about 1 in 5 million PANMs progress to PDAC.
So with this in mind, if surgery is our intervention, we can't be targeting
low-grade PANAM because
none of us would have a pancreas anymore.
We'd take them all out because we all have them.
So what we need is really biomarkers that predict risk of progression to PDAC,
not biomarkers that predict the presence of a
PANAM.We've heard a lot at this meeting about
targeting KRAS. I think it's an exciting thing to think about whether we should be
using this KRAS targeting in the prevention setting. Right?
All of these PANNs have KRAS mutations.
Most IPMNs have KRAS mutations.
But I think we can also think about how stromal targeting could also be
applied to enhance the efficacy in interception.
So with that, I want to acknowledge the folks that have done the work, including
members of my own lab, Denis and Ashley, and all of our collaborators and our
funding. And then, Ety, are we doing questions now or are we doing questions after?
Okay. Cool. I'm happy to take questions then. Thank you.
Oh, you need to go to one of the- Or you can come up here.
That's funny with this.
Yeah, it's
funny. Oh, state your name please for the recording.
Hi, I'm Ashie Woreta from Johns Hopkins.
Laura, that was beautiful as always.
It brings up the question of how perhaps making
vaccines against KRAS, as people are trying to do,
might be super useful. And how would you think about applying
those based on what you've seen with all of your great pre-cancer work?
Yeah, no, it's a great question. And when I summed up, when I said KRAS
targeting, I use that word specifically to be inclusive of either
vaccines or with KRAS inhibitors.
We've seen that the PANNs have the same mutations that are in the advanced
cancers. So vaccines that are designed to target those same KRAS
mutations could be used in the pre-cancer setting.
I think it all gets to this question of risk and how do we
identify who's at the highest risk.
The
application of interception approaches is going to depend on a cost-benefit
analysis. What are the side effects of the approach?
The vaccines have an advantage that they have very minimal side effects, so you
might think about applying those to a broader population, which is exciting.
Jen?
Hi. Thanks. Jen Morton,
CRUK Scotland Institute.
In your PANNs where you've done the CD45 analysis,
can you see a gradient of a kind of classical immune
response? So where they're low, do you get any idea what's
coming in first? Whether you've got an adaptive or an innate
response?
Yeah. Ashley, in that study, she did imaging mass cytometry on
a small number of samples, and it was more lymphocytes than
other things. But I think there's still a lot to do with profiling in
detail what exactly is there. It's a great question.
Hi. Carly Ruban. I'm at Dana-Farber.
Hi, Laura.
Hey, Carly.
I was wondering, in the
PANN research,
if any of those results, in terms of the number of lesions or the
way that the lesions were behaving, did any of that associate with age?
And did any of that associate with
if any of those 40 patients had some kind of family
history of pancreatic cancer or other
high-risk
features?
Yeah. So the 3D modeling,
to answer the second question first, none of those patients had family history, but
Ashley's group has now done and presented, I think it was at the AACR
Pancreas meeting last year, that they've now looked in 2D quantification at
patients who have a family history, and no germline mutation, and those that have
germline mutation, and those that are sporadic, and they see very different PANN
burdens between those populations.
And those that have a germline mutation have a PANN burden that's more like the
sporadic, and those that have a family history have a ton of PANN
in, a ton of fibrosis, a ton of atrophy.
And so it seems like the mechanisms of risk between the family history, no
mutation, those with a germline mutation, and those that are sporadic are very
different.
When we looked at age,
we did see if there was a correlation.
There wasn't in this data set, but I think it's not powered correctly and
was not designed to answer that question, because it was kind
of almost a cohort of convenience.
Whatever Whipple came through that had enough normal pancreas to sample, we sampled
it.
So it wasn't matched for diagnosis across age, so there's lots of confounders.
I know Marina's going to talk about her organ donor
pancreas tissue and looking at PANNs in those, and I think that's
really the right cohort to answer this question.
Thank you.
Thanks.
I do have a question. So if we have
one in 5 million-
Yeah
... that would actually be developing, and
we know that pancreatic cancer is a very
rare cancer, even though it's a terrible thing
to be that person,
what is it in the one in 5 million that actually
progresses? What's the perfect storm?
Yeah. I think we obviously don't know.
No, obviously.
But I think-
This is more a theoretical question.
No, I think it's more... Yeah, I'm happy to speculate.
Might be completely off. But I think one of the big
questions is, is your risk of getting pancreatic cancer really just about the
number of PANNs you have? Are they all the same?
So the more you have, the more likely you are to progress, in which case it gets at
this question of how do we estimate risk, right?
If that's the case, then what we really need is a tool to just measure PANN burden,
which we can't currently do on CT or traditional imaging.
So we need new imaging approaches.
But it could also be that some of these low-grade PANNs are more likely to
progress, so they're not all created equal, in which case, we need a way to image
those PANNs or identify those PANNs.
I
think that high-grade PANN, they're certainly
an important thing to target and think about, but they're very rare, and I
think that suggests that they're a very short-lived intermediate, so I think we
can't use that as our only target.
I think the other thing I want to throw out is that
when interception approaches are surgery, we have to obviously
beI'm very sure that there's a single lesion that we really want to
resect. It becomes a very different question if you have something like a vaccine
or if you were going to do interception with a KRAS inhibitor.
It can really be about whole patient risk rather than about seeing one lesion that
you want to take out surgically. So I think the entire approach to cancer
interception can really change once we have more systemic approaches to it.
And what is your thought about maybe a
mutant-specific degrader? Because
there are some
mutants that keep on coming back and back.
And getting rid of all the RAS all the time, it's probably going to be
not something very-
Yeah. No, I think that's a great point.
And even though the multifocality
of it and the fact that we all probably have every common
KRAS hot spot mutation somewhere in our pancreas, it's still a finite number of
alleles, right? It's not 100, right? It's less than 10.
And
I'm not at all a drug developer, but as we get further along in the drug
development, we already have D-specific inhibitors, V.
As you get further down to the other ones, it may be a cocktail of allele-specific,
whether it's degraders or just small molecules.
I think over the next few years, we're going to see a lot of exciting tools to
apply to pancreatic cancer, and I hope the field can think about how to apply them
earlier as well.
All right. Thank you so, so much.
Thank you.
This was wonderful. I'm going to present you from here. Is that okay?
All right. So to our next talk,
another dear friend and collaborator,
Marina Pasca di Mangliano.
Did I say it correctly?
I heard her say it and I love saying Mangliano.
So
Marina is going to talk about the evolution of pancreatic cancer
microenvironment.
Thanks, Hatti, for the introduction and for the invitation to speak, and
thanks for all of you who are staying to the bitter end of
this long meeting. And it is
particularly great to present after Laura because she introduced a
lot of the key concepts that are going to be relevant to my
talk. I have nothing to disclose.
So Laura already introduced pancreatic cancer.
I'd just like to start from the organ pancreatic cancer comes from, which is
the pancreas. And you can see here in these beautiful images,
the exocrine pancreas, the endocrine pancreas that we cancer people don't think
much about, but it's also there. And the exocrine pancreas
is formed by acinar and ducts. We don't actually know
where pancreatic cancer comes from, but when
you get pancreatic cancer, what always struck me with this disease is
that when you compare the normal pancreas on the left to cancer
on the right, you can see that the epithelium in the cancer
is really a small part of the volume, and there is a
sea of tumor microenvironment that has now replaced
the pancreas parenchyma. And I found that
striking for a long time, and one of the things more recently I've become
interested in is how do you go from here to here?
How does this microenvironment develop?
So Laura already covered this, so I don't need to belabor it,
but she explained how there are two main
precursor lesions that can lead to pancreatic cancer, IPMN
and PanIN, and my talk will only be about
PanIN for today.
So those are the questions that I will be addressing.
How common are or is PanIN or pancreatic
intraepithelial neoplasia
in the normal pancreas, like in completely healthy individuals, all
of us standing or sitting here? What is the transcriptional
landscape? What are the characteristics of the
microenvironment? And of course, can we reverse it?
Which I won't directly address, but it's something that I like to speculate
about, just like Laura just did.
So this is just a cartoon to summarize normal pancreas.
We are going to call it benign epithelium for the purpose of this talk,
PanIN, and cancer.
So one of the questions is, how
does the evolution progress in human
samples? We know a lot of it from mouse
work, where we are able to reproduce or recapitulate
tumorigenesis, but mice are not human, and the way we induce
carcinogenesis in mice is not exactly how it happens in humans.
And so we thought it was important to
study this in actual human samples, which is normally difficult because the
pancreas is not something you go and take out for no reason.
You also don't biopsy or
sample in any shape or form unless you have a reason to, but you have a reason to,
that person has some sort of disease or suspected disease, and so it's not
actually normal. So a few years ago, my team and
I had the opportunity to collaborate with Gift of Life Michigan
and with our division of transplant surgery.
Gift of Life is our state's organ donor organization.
Michigan is a relatively small state. It has 10 million inhabitants.
It's very rural.
But the one thing we had was that we
do organ procurement in a very different way than any other state
in the US, and I think anywhere in the world.
Donors on life support from the whole state are flown into
a facility on the south side of Ann Arbor, which is a tiny college
town. And so we're able to collect
tissue locally from the whole state, which
is pretty unique. And thanks to that,
this is what happens. We get a call.
Everybody in the lab goes on alert.
We receive-Bucket,
which contains a human pancreas, usually with the spleen and part of the
intestine still attached. And then we have a way we developed to
dissect it and create samples for a whole lot of uses, some of which are
described here. Relevant for today, we do single-cell
RNA sequencing. We take blocks for histology immunohistochemistry.
We also store blood, and we also make organoids, although I
won't be talking about those.
So why am I going into all these details?
Well, because the
function of the pancreas is to produce digestive enzymes, and so
when the pancreas is out of the body or when the person is
deceased, the enzymes get released from acinar cells, and they essentially start
digesting the tissue. And so if there is warm ischemia, and
that's the case of this set of donors here, viability is really
low.
So we only take donors where there is no warm ischemia, and we're able to get
very high cell viability, very intact tissue, which is really important when
you want to study the morphology, transcriptome, and other things like
that.
And so we're at about 160 donors now, but that's
the breakdown, which hasn't really changed as we update those
graphs. So we have about two-thirds male donors, one-third
female, two-thirds white, and one-third Black donors.
Importantly, our donors come from a wide range of ages, and
so that's been the other limitation in the field to be able to study the
pancreas in young individuals. And to a question that was asked before,
most surgical samples come from individuals that tend to be somewhat older.
So when we got the pancreas, we started doing histology,
and we realized that
many of them contain panin lesions. And I'm just showing you examples.
Each one of the pictures is from a different organ in a
different donor.
More pictures here. So
that's not what we were expecting.
That was before Laura's paper was out, and so we
started doing a very rough quantification, and we realized that
well more than half, and this is probably an underestimate, but
more than half of donors, even in fairly young ages, have panin
lesions.
So okay, if we all have lesions but most of us don't
get pancreatic cancer, why is that?
And one way to think about it, and this is something actually
Laura and I, together with Claus Jørgensen from Cancer UK Manchester,
have thought a lot about, and that's our working model for which we have zero
proof. But the idea is that the panin are not all
created equal. We do have proof they're quite heterogeneous, and some might
progress and some might not.
But
refocusing on the panin, the first thing we have to do is really understand what
they look like and what their characteristics are in
humans. So I'll start from the epithelium
component because even though this is a microenvironment section, obviously
everything starts from the epithelium being altered, KRAS mutations, that's
the initiating insult. And I'm going to show you work that
was largely done by Ahmed Elhosseiny, a bioinformatics
graduate student who recently graduated and left my lab and is doing a
postdoc at Memorial Sloan Kettering, and Jude Okoye, who is a
postdoc from Nigeria. Jude has done all the
immunostainings you will see, and Ahmed all the bioinformatics.
And also, I should mention, this is a collaborative effort with my colleagues Tim
Frankel and Nadine Carpenter, and with Ilana Fertig at the University of
Maryland.
So okay, the challenge is, even though almost everybody has panin,
most of the pancreas is still normal.
And so you have this small lesion in a sea of normal acini.
So how can you really characterize it?
And so we decided to use spatial transcriptomics, and we
utilized initially the 10x Visium
platform. So
with this method, you end up with a little circle
where you sequence the RNA. And so it's sort of like bulk RNA sequencing,
except you have a lot of really tiny samples per each slide.
And that's what it actually looks like.
So each of these dots is an area that was sequenced.
You can also see we lose some transcripts, but the areas that are sequenced
are either
pretty uniform or pretty heterogeneous in terms of the cells they
contain.
So we had to develop a framework to analyze it, and I'm going to
go kind of fast, but I'm happy to ask questions.
So the idea is that we have single-cell RNA sequencing and spatial
transcriptomics from the very same samples, and that allows us to do
two different things. To look at each domain just based on it
being a spatial domain in sort of a cell-agnostic manner,
but also do the convolution and then see what do the
epithelial or fibroblasts or immune cells do,
or what are they like in that domain.
And so that's an example. Those are spatial domains in healthy pancreas in
a tumor. Right now, they're just color-coded based on the
transcripts they have, so it's cell agnostic, but then we
can
refer them back to single-cell RNA sequencing from the same samples.
Now we know which type of cell has what transcripts, and that
allows us to do the convolution, which then allows us to give
names to domains. And so we end up with a number
of types of domains. Some are, for example, only acinar.
Some have fibroblasts are sort of everywhere because that's what fibroblasts
do. They're close to other cells and so on and so forth.
And so essentially, you go from something
like this with all the colors and domains numbered one to 17,
to something like this, where now those domains have names based on the
cells that are populating
them.Okay. And then if you look
across all the samples, you can see that in the normal pancreas you have a
lot of red, which is an acinar domain, because the normal
pancreas has mostly acini. But the tumors are very colorful
because the tumors are very heterogeneous, and they have a lot of different types
of cells/domains in them.
Okay. So once you get there, you can start comparing.
And so the one very simple comparison is
looking at prevalence of certain types of cells.
And so tumors have more macrophages, they have
more of other immune cells. They lose acinar cells, so acinar
cells are more common in healthy. And then you can see
when you look at the fibroblasts, which are one of my favorite cell types, you
start seeing a tail on each end. That's because
some fibroblasts are more common in normal, while others
are more common in tumor. But if we do things this way, we sort of are
not using the spatial information.
We did all that work and spent all that money to get spatial data, and now we
are treating it like single cell. So we didn't want to do that.
So,
the way we went about it is, first of all, going back to the
domains, we can map the domains that contain the epithelial
transcripts, and that gives us an idea
that things are a little more complicated than we thought.
So when we look at all the benign domains, they're all in adjacent
red and green and blue here are acinar domains.
The ductals are in purple, are clearly separate, but the neoplastic
domains are almost their own thing. They're completely separate.
And so if we now take the neoplastic domains
only and we put them together, what you're seeing is a couple of things.
First of all, they're contiguous.
The pannexin that come from either adjacent normal or donor
are all in one area. And then you have glandular tumor, and then
you have poorly differentiated tumor in pink.
But if you look carefully, there are a few
donor pannexin that are actually quite far into
the tumor area. So you start getting the idea that things
are not quite as simple and not all pannexin are created
equal.
So the other thing is that if we do this analysis using domains,
we then want to know are the differences really driven by transcripts in
epithelial cells? And we can do then deconvolution and look only at
epithelial transcripts. So we go from something like this to only
looking at epithelial transcripts.
And now we can see, first of all, they still fall in
groups that correspond to the samples, to the
histology they came from. But also we can
compare and do differences. And so,
I will only show you one thing because we don't have much time.
One of the differences
was IL6/JAK-STAT3 signaling, which is highly enriched in
poorly differentiated tumors. So that's something we could easily validate,
which Jude did by immunostaining.
This is showing
pannexin where you do not see phospho-STAT3,
a well-differentiated tumor and then poorly
differentiated tumor. And if I use high mag, you can clearly
see that in pannexin if you have phospho-STAT3, it's usually in the
microenvironment where it is also found.
In tumors, you have a lot of nuclear phospho-STAT3.
So okay, that's great. That tells us that pannexin have some of tumor
characteristics. They are continuous, but they're different.
They haven't acquired higher regulation of STAT3 and other pathways
which I didn't have time to go into.
But what about the microenvironment?
And that's when we really needed to be able to use the spatial information.
And so we decided to use neighborhood
analysis where histology and
transcriptomics allowed us to identify different
structures. And the structures I'm showing you here are ducts, which are really
nice because there are normal ducts in both healthy samples and
in tumor samples, so they are almost an internal control.
And then we have
a pannexin in the donor samples. And then GL tumors stands for
glandular tumor, which is kind of the same as well differentiated and then poorly
differentiated tumor. Okay, so this is a little complicated, so I'll
break it down. If you look at ducts, whether they are in normal
or in cancer samples, their neighbors, which are
color-coded around, are the same with the only exception that if you're
in a tumor slide, you're going to have some tumor nearby.
So that makes sense.
Then we looked at
both immune cells and at
fibroblasts. And so that's where we started finding a couple of interesting
differences. So
pannexin have accumulated plasma cells
nearby.
There is an increase compared to normal ducts.
It's not huge, but there are plasma cells around.
There are much fewer plasma cells around tumor
structures. But you now see this population of
macrophages in teal that is expanded specifically
around tumor. And so if you look at it a different way, which is maybe a little
easier to look at, you can see that this is percentage of
types of cells within the neighborhood.
And you can see that there is an enrichment of plasma cells around pannexin,
but not around tumor, and conversely, macrophages are enriched around
tumor. It doesn't mean macrophages are not around pannexin.
They're there, but they're not enriched in the neighborhood.
They're just equally dispersed.
And this is just some immunostaining to show you plasma cells around pannexin and
not very many around tumor. They're actually overall a tumor slide
will have more plasma cells, but they're in TLSs,
in tertiary lymph structures. They're not actually near the epithelial
structures.So to summarize that, there is a rearrangement
of immune cells where you go from having plasma cells near
the epithelium and macrophages sort of equally dispersed, to
accumulating macrophages and pushing away the plasma cells.
And then I wanted to get to my favorite cell type,
also good because that's probably what Eti will also talk about later,
which is fibroblasts. So we found different fibroblast populations, and
I'm showing you this light blue one,
which is present everywhere, but it goes slightly down in tumor.
And then there is this brown population of fibroblasts that is only
present near tumor structures.
So another way to look at it is to look at it on the actual slide.
And so you can see there is tumor in pink and orange, and there are the
brown fibroblasts there. You don't see any in a healthy slide.
There were actually other fibroblast populations that I'm not talking about.
This dark blue is at the periphery. They might be mesothelial cells.
And the
lilac ones are associated with vasculature
and adipose areas. And so
I'm not going to show you more about those.
But the
fibro-2 and fibro-3, as we call them, they are close epithelial
structures. Fibro-3 is everywhere. It goes slightly down in tumors.
Fibro-2 is tumor specific. So what are they?
So to know that, we went back onto our single cell
analysis, and now we can compare with much more
depth
the presence of different fibrous populations.
And there are two that are specifically enriched in tumor samples
compared to healthy or adjacent normal.
They've changed color because this is a different analysis, but the result is the
same. There is unique fibroblasts in tumor areas.
And when we went to look at what they have,
they have a lot of things, but I'm just going to point out a few.
They have high expression of smooth muscle actin, which is encoded
by ACTA2. They have a high expression of LEF1.
In one of these two tumor-specific populations, it's rich in
LRC15, which is a traditional CAF
marker or cancer-associated fibroblast marker.
So again, we like to validate everything by immunostaining.
This is just showing you a number of different pannin, each in a different donor.
Yellow is PDGF receptor alpha and beta, which is just essentially a
pan fibroblast marker. And this slide just tells you fibroblasts are
around lesions.
And also it's a very pretty staining, so I figure I should have
it. But now we are going to go more specific.
PDGF receptor is now in white. This is a pannin, and you
can see a lot of fibroblasts around.
But this slide is also stained for SMA in red
and LRC15 in green, and you don't actually see any green.
You see a little bit of red, but that's because SMA is also
around blood vessels and other structures.
And this unfortunately got blurry, but you can see a lot
of green and red. So those fibroblasts in a tumor slide
are now very high for those CAF markers.
And then this is LEF1. On the left, you don't
really see any specific LEF1 staining.
It's supposed to be
nuclear. On the right, you can see a lot of LEF staining, specifically in
the fibroblasts that are interspersed within the tumor area.
So that's quantified here. So to summarize, before
I run out of time, I showed you that pannin is really common
in humans, even in very young individuals, which again
underscores the point that Laura made, which most pannin will not
progress. Their transcriptional landscape is unique.
The microenvironment is completely distinct from that of cancer, which raises the
question of, is that restraining progression?
And when you get to cancer, is
the microenvironment change preceding or following
the actual progression of pannin to cancer?
And then I didn't actually took the data out because I figured I would be out of
time. I forgot to take out a point. But in mice, work from my
lab many years ago and current work with RAS inhibitors
clearly shows you can reverse pannin by inhibiting oncogenic
KRAS.
And there are, of course, a lot of future plans, but
the point of intercepting pannin by using RAS
inhibitors is really interesting, and it is not easy to figure out how to do
that with human samples. But it's something we're actively thinking about.
Maybe organoids are going to be the way to do.
And
the relationship between changes in the epithelium and the microenvironment is also
something we're interested in exploring.
And I mentioned the people involved in the work before, so I'll
just take any questions.
Irina, another beautiful talk. I'm very curious about your
SFRP4 signature, because we're seeing a lot of
SFRPs increase in the microenvironment of fibroblasts in aged
tumor settings. And you mentioned sort of at the beginning of your talk that you
have a wide age range of these samples.
So is there a correlation between these fibroblast phenotypes you're seeing
and the age of the patients, or is it just-
So we don't know yet, but that's definitely something.
So that one of the things that our cohort, now that it is so large, will allow
us to do will be exactly looking at that kind of
change.
For example, in aged individuals, maybe the microenvironments have already acquired
some of those more cancer-promoting abilities, and given all
your work on aging fibroblasts, we're very
interested in looking at that. We also have made primary fibroblasts from most
of those pancreata. They're not terribly happy to grow,
but they're primary cells. They'll be in culture for a little bit.
So
there is some more we can maybe do with that, too.
There.
Hey, I'm Orion Stepton from Johns Hopkins.
I was wondering if you saw any
particular signaling between the type 2
fibroblasts and the tumor cells, and if that's different from the
other signaling between the fibroblasts that you're seeing.
Yeah. So they definitely make a different set of
ligands.
We are still mapping out, so we actually have a new graduate student
now who's looking exactly at that, mapping out.
So he's using a combination of spatial and then
cell-cell interaction type algorithm, so we can look for
interactions that are within a certain spatial domain.
There are definitely differences. We haven't fully mapped them out.
Wnt signaling seems to be one of them.
So I didn't show the data again because of time, but the other markers that go
up are Wnt ligands in both epithelial cells and in fibroblasts,
different Wnts, and then they each have receptors.
So I don't yet know how the pathway exactly is going to work out, but that's
definitely one that's increased.
And then inflammatory pathways, which might
maybe talk to a third party like immune cells.
So
there are both new interactions between epithelial and
fibroblasts, but also new interactions with other cell types.
Thank you.
Here. Julia Piaggio from Comprehensive Cancer
Center in Rome in Italy. And really
congratulation, fascinating results,
really. Especially for the way in which you collect the
samples. That is a resource,
really important. And related to this, my question
is a question and a comment.
Do you think that this pannin, this
so silent pannin, actually are already
orchestrating a
crosstalk with the periphery? And so do you think that
should be important to take also spleen, bone marrow,
and blood from these donors? Should be
really important to understand if there is a perturbation of
the entire body, not only-
Yeah. No, that's a really good point.
So, in mice, we know that that's the case
because in mice it's easy to do.
In human it's harder to do, but we do
collect. It's interesting, it's just a couple of weeks ago we were
talking about... So the bone marrow actually gets collected from the
donors because it goes into bone marrow banks for
leukemia patients later on. So that actually becomes
available,
if they have excess of what they need for clinical use.
Obviously, the first rule is we can't interfere with anything
important for patients. So we get the pancreas when there is no
call for transplantation. We get blood because there is more blood than
you need. So we are collecting blood.
If we get the spleen, we dissociate it and then
freeze live single cells.
And
the bone marrow we haven't been getting, but I think it would be interesting
to start getting that information too.
May I suggest you can have a look if mutated
KRAS is already present, for example, in bone marrow
due to
crosstalk-
Yeah
... the cellular vesicle. But-
Yeah. And the other thing that would be interesting to do is see whether there are
already lymphocytes that are responsive to RAS
mutations. So yeah.
Yeah.
Very good idea.
Up there.
Hey, very great talk. Shamming from Moderna Therapeutics.
So I'm wondering,
have you ever explored some of the functions regarding these
specific fibroblasts you identified with
SFR4 higher and also the IRC15
higher groups? And recently, there
are, I think, several groups reporting there is a
fibroblasts with
antigen-presenting sort of functions.
And have you ever looked into if these are
also in any of the group of your fibroblasts?
Yeah. So,
for the first part of the question, we've done a lot of functional work in mice.
Unfortunately, that's a case where mouse and human are not exactly the same, and so
that's a little bit a challenge.
We have
identified a population of
probably fibroblasts that are high in CD74 and
antigen-presenting machinery, but it's a little...
The reason I didn't present this is that we're trying to make
sure it is really fibroblasts. Fibroblasts and macrophages are often really
close to one another,
and it can be really hard to make sure.
And then fibroblasts, they don't have a super clear membrane.
It's not like an epithelial cell where you can be really sure the marker is
there and not in the other cell type.
So we're still trying to sort it out.
So yeah, I don't have a full answer.
And then we also have these fibroblasts that are sort of lying in the periphery,
and those seem, I think they're probably mesothelial cells.
But we're still working to confirm that, too.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you so much.
All right, so I'm not going to introduce myself.
I'm going to just start.
Thank you so much. Oh, I need the thingy.
Are you using just the keyboard to change? Yeah. Okay.
I use a mouse. Yeah.
Okay. Sorry. I was supposed to know this.
All right. So if you scan this
QR code, you're going to get to the lab.
I also
used to be more media crazy for science.
I still do a little bit of that. So any of these means is going to be
good to get in contact with us and with the lab.
All right. So I do have a little bit of disclosures, are mostly
collaborators. I don't get a lot of or anything
from them, but I do need to disclose them.
Mostly we collaborate with companies where we get
reagents or we're testing a little bit of their software or their
hardware, and we do have
aspiring to make some patents in the future, but we have nothing
really truly to disclose. All right.
So I'm really, really happy I made the decision to
be the last because I don't have to do a lot of explanation about all of this
evolution of the pancreata during
tumorigenesis. But I do want to utilize this little cartoon
to emphasize that all compartments in the pancreata
change as the evolution of the tumor
begins and progresses throughout the human life,
and that we can utilize these
ideas as an all-inclusive problem of the entire organ.
And this is, like every other cancer, eventually a
systemic disease. And so we need to think about it both
in the single cell but also in the context of
everything together, the tumor mass and the human individual that is
undergoing these processes. And the easiest thing to
me for explaining this is always thinking about ecology, and
therefore, the ecology of cancer is a perfect analogy to
understand that the ecological niche is really, really
important, and that's how we think about the microenvironment in
cancer.
And so this brings me very naturally to the seed and soil
idea. And in the 1800s, this was thought of
as where the cells will metastasize because people who
developed this idea were surgeons,
mostly for female with breast cancer.
And they started to note that they metastasize mostly to lung
and bone and brain, but almost never to other sites, and came up with the
idea of the seed and soil. The perfect analogy here is to think
that even if we have already the driver mutations,
like Laura beautifully told us, that
the lesions already have KRAS mutations,
and it's going to eventually be one clone that will
keep the KRAS and develop into cancer.
So in theory, we can have already the seed
fully ready to germinate, but if there is no fertile
land,
it will wait until there is maybe a fire, and
then there is going to be a true germination.
So the soil, again, is super important.
I'm going to use throughout the talk TS and TP, which is
naturally tumor-suppressive stroma or TP, naturally
tumor-progressing stroma. So we need the perfect storm, both the
mutations within the seed and the land need to be
fertilized in order for us to get a tumorigenesis and a
full-grown cancer, where the soil now will be
tumor-promoting stroma. And under these circumstances, we can
think that if we want to intercept or prevent, we would
need an agent or some type of interception
that could keep the dry land. And so we will
not develop cancer eventually, which is one of the ways to do
this. Other ways is to try and dry the land so we
can regain control
of the tumor and not have
the disease itself to have
potentially a chronic disease within individuals that are going to
be healthy.
Other ideas are based on this consortium at the
NCI, the cancer prevention and
interception, where we're trying to look for agents to
actually intercept and prevent cancer.
And so if the
cancer has been primed and there is-- Oh, I'm sorry.
If the cancer has been primed and there's already a little bit of
development, maybe a high grade
of panning or there are already accumulation of more mutations,
the stroma seems to be already predisposed in some cases,
and we would be able to dry this land again if we find the right
reagent and try to then again regain and intercept and
prevent.
So all of these things are things that keeps
myself up at night. And in the lab, we think about all of
this all the time, and I'm going to give you a couple of examples of how
we go about it with the stroma as a point
of focus in the lab.
So what is in the soil? What the soil is made of?
Well, the soil in pancreatic cancer is all of the mesenchymal
component that Marina showed us beautifully.
The stroma is taking over all the epithelium, and this
stroma is supported by the local fibroblastic
cells. And I'm using this on purpose because there are the mesothelial cells, the
pancreatic stellate cells, the bona fide fibroblasts.
All of these are responsible for making the interstitial extracellular
matrix. And all of the cells within the tumor microenvironment will
be residing within this unit, fibroblastic extracellular
matrix-generated unit. And there is where we're going to find the
local immune cells. And this
environment, when there is no disease, is responsible
of the homeostasis of the organ and also the
homeostasis of the disease itself because it's a chronic
situation that dynamically changes but reaches every
time some type of an equilibrium.So within
this in mind,
the key aspect to understand using a third analogy for
cancer, if we think about cancer as perpetual wounds, we
can then understand that a wound that resolves, a
acute wound that the pannex are
these temporary lesions that have to
resolve. And I actually think that pannex that never progress
may have been acutely healed by the
stroma, and with a good resolution of the wound,
there is going to be always an anti-tumor effect and make sure that
this doesn't progress evolutionary.
Yet when there is a chronic wound healing and there is no resolution,
that is when we have tissue regeneration perpetuated
and cancer progressing. So that's the analogy
we think about in the lab.
So with this, I need to tell a very quick story.
So when I started my lab and I didn't know much about all of the field
in cancer, I went to my first cancer meeting, and
it was a room as big as this, full of people, and they
were debating and fighting almost in the
discussions, saying whether the somatic theory
is the right theory of initiation of cancer.
I'm not talking of germline or any childhood
cancers. And then the other team that was very vocal, but
not a lot of people, they were saying that is the tissue organization
field theory. One was saying, "We don't need mutations at
all. We just need the stroma to change." And the other one was, "We care
nothing about the stroma. We only need mutations to change." But I
like peace. I really do like peace.
And so I think that both were right, and these are not mutually exclusive,
and that both of them were right. And I was very, very happy and
fortunate to be at Fox Chase Cancer Center, where the two hit
theory father, Alt Knudson, actually 40
years after he came up with the tumor suppression idea of
the loss of heterogeneity for
actually having a tumor suppressor no longer be suppressor, 40
years later said, "Oh, you know what?
The tumor microenvironment should be also considered a tumor
suppressor that needs to be overcome in order for us to
get cancer." And I was very fortunate to talk about him about that.
In any case, this dry land needs to be overcame in
order for us to be able to get tumorigenesis.
And so for interception or control, we aim
to sustain or regain this
microenvironmental tumor suppression.
And that is what the lab stands for, and those are our
all the goals in the lab. So why did we choose pancreatic
cancer as a model? Well, there's not a lot I need to say anymore
after Laura's and Marina's talk, but I do want to bring up a
personal reason for me to study pancreatic cancer, which is
trailblazer of the tumor microenvironment person who came
up with the idea that in the demonstration, the
tumor-associated collagen signatures are traits that are
fully indicating of whether or not the patient will do
better or worse. And this is my dear friend, Pat Keeley,
who very ironically died from her third cancer, which was
pancreatic cancer. And in 2017, I decided to
dedicate the lab to her memory and study, and focus
specifically on pancreatic cancer.
Obviously, there is many scientific reasons as well.
The sea of stroma that Marina was talking about, the
reason that pancreatic cancer is very
rare, and if we compare it to lung, two individuals out of
100 in the population may have a risk to develop
pancreatic cancer, while one out of 19 will develop lung
cancer. Yet pancreatic cancer currently stands as the
third most lethal cancer. And so,
it really needs attention, although we're very hopeful with all of these
new revolution pun intended,
treatments.
There is also a ton of genetic and polygenic
risks that are
increasing the risk of pancreatic cancer.
And we, in the prevention idea for pancreatic
cancer, are thinking about individuals that have this risk because the
risk is enormously increased, especially if
they come from families with immediate first
relatives that develop pancreatic cancer.
So I think I convince you that pancreatic cancer stroma will be important to
study. Now, I want to come back to this same cartoon and have
the tumor and the stroma just separated into two types of compartments,
and try to think about the fact that the normal microenvironment
and the benign microenvironment, and the tumor microenvironment are
different and co-evolving. And then I want to give a shout
to both of the presentations that we heard at the beginning.
So the Gift of Life from Marina's lab has demonstrated
beautifully that even at the benign time,
the stroma is no longer normal, and that these lesions
have a unique stroma that needs to be studied and
understand. And then Laura has also shown us
that when there is some type of a disease in the pancreata
that is being analyzed for these precancerous lesions,
that stroma is also notNormal and very different
from the areas or from the ones that Marina was
studying. And it will be really, really interesting now that, and
forever that they collaborate to find out the similarities and the differences
because the populations are so different between the ones that they are
studying. And I'm very lucky to be a
collaborator
of both of them, so I can also take a look at both of
the microenvironments from these super precious collections
of both of them. And I'll explain myself how the way that we analyze
these environments is very complementary to the ways that they analyze these
microenvironments. And the third type of thinking that we need
to bring into the table, especially in an interception or prevention
type of stroma meeting session, is to
think about people that have risks and predispositions.
And think about if we have a germline predisposition like BRCA,
it's been beautifully shown that the stroma, not only the cancer cell
intrinsic DNA repair mechanism is altered,
but the stroma function itself is completely different in individuals that
bear these mutations at birth. Rudi
Schouwe showed that in breast, for example, and there is
several other genetic and non-genetic
studies that are
defining the changes in the stroma itself for
individuals that have familial predispositions.
So all of this, I think is enough
to try and convince you that the stroma will be important for
interception. And this is the third little piece of information,
where
in the past we demonstrated this in that QR code in that paper
for the animal models. But the image that you're seeing here is for
human,
where we can see that in the normal pancreata versus the benign
pancreata versus the pancreata that is bearing cancer, we
can use some of our biomarkers that are determinants of the
tumor-promoting stroma already being predisposed at the
benign aspect. Now, this is a very
small cohort of individuals, and all of these benign
samples were from pancreata of patients with bona fide pancreatic
cancer. And so we know that at least the adjacent
area of the pancreata that was
resected by surgery was already predisposed even far
away from the tumor based on this set of
biomarkers.
And so that too suggests that if we
could normalize the stroma, at least based on these type of
markers, we potentially could gain that control or that
prevention. All right, so how do we go about doing this?
In the lab, what we do is we collaborate with surgeons.
We get the benign tissue and the tissue itself near
and far of the cancer fresh, and we isolate
fibroblasts. And because I am a fibroblast biologist
that was made into a cancer biologist, what we do for
fibroblasts is try to not stress them by the biomechanics of the
underlying substrate, which is a lot of people that are not in
this room are going on in the parallel room, unfortunately.
And then what we do is to allow the fibroblasts to generate their own
extracellular matrices so they can relax into themselves and
then study their traits and study their functions.
And here you can see, immediately recognize the
organization of Pat Keeley's collagen signatures, where
the tumor-promoting areas are very clearly
very different from the tumor-suppressive areas.
And we characterize this. We collect their conditioned media.
We can see some systemic differences.
We can put cancer cells and see whether they thrive in the princess.
We can genetically manipulate one to look and behave like the other and
vice versa. And there are many, many different traits to this type
of approach because
both Marina and Laura have been telling us there's many types of
functional
situations where fibroblasts will dynamically change what they're doing.
And all of these traits can tell us about what they're doing, not to speak
about all of the lineages and high heterogeneity between
all of the fibroblasts. And so we do a little bit of tissue engineering
as well. We get rid of the fibroblasts, so we can have these
scaffolds and now study how this
matrix can help control the functional state of
repopulated matrices, where we can co-culture
and reconstitute the tumor, the stroma, the immune, all
of them together, and vice versa. And so this is an
approach that we do with human cells.
We also have human models to perpetuate some of the phenotypes and the
functions. And with these, we were thinking that we can use it as a
preclinical approach where we want to dry the land and start
studying how to do that. And if we wanted to do agent
screening, we also need to think about it in a high throughput manner
or medium throughput manner because it's very unpractical to do this high
throughput.
And one of the ways that we develop is a poster that was presented
by Maria, who is sitting here in the audience today.
And she designed a mold where we can co-culture at least
four mini
two-millimeter
units and use this microfluidic chamber for the sequential
immunofluorescence, where she can do dozens of
biomarkers in the same units for the same patient, and she can do this
for several patients at a time. And by using these with
many colors and many traits, she was able to demonstrate that even
two individuals that we have functionally stated
and convinced ourselves that their stroma is
pro-tumorigenicThey have very different traits, and
they're probably very distinct from each other.
This is highly resolved. We can do and question many
biomarkers at the different cellular
compartments, and
try to figure out the biology behind this at the protein level,
post transcriptionally modify proteins and
extracellular markers, as well as intracellular ones.
And with this, she still can do it in 3D, and we're very excited
about this approach because we can, for example, distinguish epithelial to
mesenchymal cells from bona fide fibroblastic units,
and we can also characterize them very clearly and
very precisely, and we can also figure out the differences between the
patients. So the whole idea here is that if we have many traits, we
can actually be
very careful in characterizing the fibroblastic function.
And we came up with a harmonic output of stromal traits where
we, pun intended, called this the host factor.
The higher host factor, the more protumorogenic, the lower the
host factor, the less protumorogenic.
I don't know that it's tumor suppressive, but it will be less tumorogenic.
And so under these conditions, in a medium throughput
manner, we can then do perturbations to these units and start
figuring out whether we can change their traits.
And so what are the targets, you may ask.
Well, back in 2021, we demonstrated that one of the
targets may be netrin G1, who is driving protumorogenic
functions through different pathways, and that in vivo, this can
be targeted to normalize the stroma.
So that's, for example, one way to do it.
And so we decided to screen some antibodies against this target, for
example, and try to figure out whether we can normalize the stroma.
But poor Alex figure out that we didn't have very good tools, that we were
still manually doing a lot of our digital imaging analysis, and he
was going nuts. And so he decided to develop some
pipelines, so we can actually do this in a medium throughput way.
And you're welcome to use these tools.
They're publicly available if you were to screen these, and it's been
recorded. And with that, we were able to start trying to
use means to normalize the stroma in vitro,
and we published the first paper trying to do this,
which I will mention in a minute what is this paper about.
But this is the first time we published the harmonic output of stromal traits,
and we are calling it up to this single value, the host
factor. But if we're trying to do interception, one of the things is not
just the traits, it's also the functions.
So we needed cancer-initiated cells,
benign cells that are not tumorogenic, and try to demonstrate that these
terrible microenvironments cause these cells to thrive, but they're
not bad to normal cells. So there is a
predisposition that is needed, and we came up with this way to
try and do it at the precancerous state.
And for that, this initiated epithelial cells needed to be
generated in the lab. So that's what we did, and then we
did it in
premalignant assays of functional thriving of these cells
and not the normal, obviously, using the pancreatic
cancer as controls. And so Alex was
able to generate a predisposed ATM and a
predisposed PALB2 germline
based on human pancreatic epithelial cells that were
immortalized, and we demonstrated that none of this is tumorogenic
upon injection into SCID mice. And with this, we were
able to do all of these screens in vitro and come up with maybe
the best antibody out of the few that we were
comparing. But we needed to vet these also in vitro, so we
needed to have interception models to go in vivo as
well. And so we have syngeneic
orthotopic ones, but we also have syngeneic
in immune-compromised mice, where we can co-inject
the precancerous cells together with terrible fibroblasts and then try
to intercept that. And so in order for us to do that, we
needed to figure out how to do the host factor
in these tissues, and I will show you that in a minute, and
then use these agents to try and intercept.
So the very first model that we came up, which is very
preliminary and
completely not vetted yet, but we have some preliminary data,
was based on this
one paper approach that came out in 1999,
where it was demonstrated that initiated epithelial prostate
cells injected subcutaneously can
definitely cause cancer if they are co-injected with
CAF. But if they are co-injected with normal cells or if
normal epithelial cells together with terrible fibroblasts are co-injected,
you would not get lesions. And so we took this idea
and did it orthotopically using these precancerous cells from the
humanlines that Alex developed,
and we tried to co-inject those
orthotopically together with tumor-promoting CAF.
And what we have here, which we're not 100% sure
whether we're aggravating the local pancreata or these are truly
the human cells that we injected, but we can
see a little bit of precancerous lesions only in the
animals that were co-injected with the fibroblasts, and then
some early
benign,
low-grade pannex starting to develop as well
with some cells that
may tell us that something is developing there with a little bit of
inflammation. I'm doing all of this very shaking
here because Laura is sitting there, so we can talk later.
But I think that's what we're seeing here, and we are ready to
start doing some of the screens in these animals.
But we're also doing the regular approaches that everybody
else does in the very well-established precancerous
lesions. This image was sent to me by Maria when I was going through
a hard time, and they wanted to cheer me up, so I couldn't help not showing it.
So we are using the KPC mice. We're doing the seroline, trying to get
more high grade and trying to inhibit.
And when we did this precancerous situation with the best antibody that
we did in our screens, we got a little bit better from the
commercial antibody that we didn't like much.
So we were not sure that this is the best way to do it.
I was too relaxed, and I'm taking a lot of time, so I'm going to start going a
little faster. We have other targets, what we think
that are a little more directly driving the
stroma. With these, we made some peptides that
were really supposed to prevent the ligand and
the receptor to bind and then intercept the stroma.
But the problem is that when we use them in vivo together
with the control peptides, the control peptides were immunogenic
as much as the real peptides, and we were curing the mice
both ways. So we think that we need to rethink about protein
design, and Roland Dombrach is helping us to do that with
new peptides and in his facility, also with small molecules.
In the meantime, we wanted to do different approaches.
So I'm going to really run to tell you how we got this to the clinic.
We collaborate with Josh Meyer, who demonstrated back
in 2017 that if we give radiation to
healthy animals, but in a pulse, as opposed to continuous
beam approach, the animals will not be systemically
or locally inflamed. And so what we wanted to do
is to try and do chemoradiation to our units
in pulses or in continuously. And what we demonstrated in
this paper that just came out about a week or
two ago,
we demonstrated that in this in vitro system that definitely is
normalizing functionally the units, their traits
were very difficult to tell. And so we needed to use the host
factor and put a lot of traits together in order to
demonstrate that the normalization was there because we couldn't find one
single target
biomarker that would tell us that the stroma was normalized.
And so this is the paper where we demonstrated that we need the host
factor, and we decided to take this to the clinic.
This clinical trial was done with the help of all
of these amazing individuals and many others at Fox
Chase, and we needed to now gate and find the host factor in
the tissues. With that, these are very simplified maps
where you can see very different colors for the different compartments,
fibroblasts in cyan, immune cells in yellow, and the two types of
well-differentiated and poorly differentiated cancer cells.
In using this approach in patients, we
were willing to try and understand what is the functional
repercussion of doing this to patients.
I'm going to show you the controls of the trial because we haven't done the patient
samples yet. But exactly like Marina and
Laura were saying, we have a lot of different fibroblasts.
We have 80 different fibroblasts and only 14 in
common for patients that were never treated or treated like we
always do with the continuous radiation.
And then the new sets of functional fibroblasts are all
tumor-promoting, and they have very complicated
many biomarkers within them. The color coding here, the
darker the color, the more protumorogenic.
And you can see that the stroma was not so terribly protumorogenic in
patients that were not treated. But there is an enormous amount
of cancer, and the patients are thriving,
and the cancer has already disseminated in most of these patients.
While patients treated with the continuous radiation and the chemotherapy
have
nice control of their cancer, not completely gone, but their stroma is
completely said to be protumorogenic.
And so the goal for the PLDR trial is to try and get rid of the
cancer without aggravating the stroma, hopefully to be able to
harness the natural tumor suppression of the stroma or the
opportunity to target the stroma in a way that it will be meaningful as
well.
The last but not least was us being very scared that with
the regular ways that we are treating the patients, we're aggravating the
stroma. So the four to six weeks that
they're waiting for until they have their surgery, we came up with
this other type of clinical trial where we're trying to normalize their
stroma before they go through surgery. This trial has ended as well.
We have all the samples as well, and all of them are going to go through the
same exact analysis together with the precancerous samples that
we're going to get from Laura and from Marina.
And we're running very similar other trials at Fox Chase.
So if you remember anything about this, is that
studying fibroblasts as functional units has been
really enormously rewarding to us.
And , really, we can do this.
And teamwork is dream work. And so this is the
village in the lab. Currently, the individuals that have asterisks
are right now in the lab. And we have tons of amazing
collaborators and funding.
Shout out to the CAPIT.
And I also want to encourage you to use the AACR
journals,
very well-recognized faces as our chief editors.
And this is an open access journal that we all definitely
needed to take advantage for if we want to publish with
government money.
And I thank you, and I went over the time, but we're still okay
with three or four minutes for questions if you're interested